well
so a young person starting their career
i think there are probably a lot of
things that some of them are very well
known and people have heard them many
times they're still true one of those
that you should always focus on a young
person should find something that
they're passionate about to do
and
that's not gonna surprise anyone it's
it's a clear thing to do it's very hard
if you don't love your work you're never
gonna be great at it the other thing i
would suggest to
any young person even before they start
their career
is to really think about their choices
because
i find young people and i i when i was
young i had i made this mistake too
you can get
very fixed
on your gifts so everybody has gifts you
know you you have gifts you have things
that you didn't get gifted maybe you're
extremely beautiful maybe you're
extremely good at mathematics maybe you
there are a lot of things that you can
be given
but those things can confuse you because
they're not the things that construct
your life it's your choices
that construct your life not your gifts
you can celebrate your gifts be proud of
them be happy of them actually don't be
proud of them
be celebratory of them because you can't
be proud because they're gifts they were
given to you you didn't earn them you
can only be proud of the things you earn
and so as i got older i started to
realize i wasn't proud of my gifts i was
always good at school school was always
easy for me and i was always proud that
i was a great student i got a's in all
my classes
i was good at math all of that and i
thought
i thought that's who i was but it's not
true
those are the things that are gifts what
was hard for me is deciding to work hard
deciding to
use my gifts in certain ways to
challenge myself to
do things that i didn't think i could do
to put myself in uncomfortable
situations
we all get i would say to a young person
you can choose a life
of ease and comfort or you can choose a
life of service and adventure which one
of those when you're 90 years old
are you going to be more proud of
if i were a young college student today
i would be very interested in
biotechnology i think biotechnology is a
just a fascinating arena that probably
in the near in the next 10 or 20 years
is going to be a golden age of biotech
one of the golden ages that's happening
right now before our eyes is also
artificial intelligence and machine
learning so that's another arena that i
would i would be very interested in my
backup career is i'm a very good
bartender so if all else fails
you'll see me at the local bar and i'll
be making your drinks slowly but they'll
be good
that was never plan b um
the real plan b if amazon hadn't worked
out i would be an extremely happy
software programmer
i actually don't like plan b's i i find
plan b's are um
they defocus you from plan a plan b
should always be make plan a work people
have very high standards for
how they want their work life to be
and uh
and i said look if you can get your work
life
to be where you enjoy half of it that is
amazing because very few people ever
achieve
that because the truth is everything
comes with overhead that's reality
everything comes with pieces that you
don't like you could be a supreme court
justice and there's still going to be
pieces of your job you don't like you
can be a university professor and it's
still going to be you have to go to
committee meetings and you have to do
you know there every job comes with
pieces you don't like and we need to say
that's just how that's part of it and
not resent those pieces or try not to
but also try to minimize them i tell
senior executives
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird i think false
idea that ceos i'm a ceo there's this
false idea that ceos are under the most
stress
well i look at that i'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress
it's your choice
and uh
so it's you have to figure out how to
set up your life in such a way that you
can minimize the things and i find
people don't dislike hard work what
people dislike is being out of control
like they can't control their life they
can't control their environment this
happens to me
when i get over scheduled i hate being
over scheduled i want some time to be
able to think and free myself we all
have the same amount of time in the
world
nobody has more time than anybody else
and when you become a very successful
person
one of the things you start to get over
scheduled and so you have to guard your
time and and and try to say a little bit
flexible so that's for me it's not a
waste of time but i like to have some
freedom of movement rather than having
every minute of every day
scheduled
one thing i could have
more of the obvious answer is time
i like time
i don't i'm not efficient with my time
because
efficiency
there's an embedded assumption
when you're being efficient and the
embedded assumption is that you know
where you're going and i like to wander
because it's wandering that allows you
to invent and to explore and to follow
your curiosity but wandering is very
time consuming
and so if i could have one more thing it
would just be more time
you